hello everybody and thanks for watching
again for part two of our version of
Kobe and interview today we have some
questions that you all sent in on the
YouTube channel and on Twitter so I'm
gonna go ahead and ask for some the
questions that you focus on in today
first question is from 10 Pakistan he
wants to know who's your favorite player
currently and who's your favorite player
of all time well my currently favorite
player is Levon Aronian and the all-time
lactea grande Petrosyan and anatoly
karpov 10 would also like to know that
if you have any suggestions for him for
4 good books for beginners books I can
recommend Bobby Fischer teaches chess
book for beginners it's a very popular
and a good book that's a very popular
book here at the club - we suggest a lot
to beginners let's see Andrew Isabel
would like to know that other than your
American Open win against key Evra
what's some of your most beautiful games
you've ever played a particular one that
stands out yeah there there is another
game I can think of is a game against
Grandmaster Bartonella from the
millionaire chess tournament it was a
nice tactical win as well and didn't
with some good sacrifices I had also had
a positional very good game against
grandmasters Rossini but it was just
different just a pure positional game we
actually got three questions here from
Amanda Mangesh ba da da his first
question is other than chess what's your
favorite sport to play and watch I like
to play in watch soccer soccer you have
a favorite team favorite League my
favorite team is barceló not from Spain
my favorite legally the English Premier
League lots of action and that's
optional very intense matches yeah it's
probably the most popular league in the
world I know a lot of people who follow
Premiership action mangesh would also
like to know when you're preparing for a
tournament for a match is your is your
schedule more rigorous chess
schedule or is it more structured
structured schedule I like to plan my
date so I you know have time to prepare
for the games properly also have time to
rest and you know get some food before
the game and just make sure that I'm
very calm and relaxed and well the rest
so that's the most important thing I
think to play well so it's important not
just to be prepared with chess but to be
prepared mentally physically absolutely
to exercise make sure you know you're
you know decent shape for the tournament
is it clear as well and do some chest
preparation too but overall you have to
be well rested have no make sure you get
some good sleep as well last question
from me engage you have a lot of fans in
India volure very popular there Mangesh
would like to know if you have any plans
of going to India soon or maybe
competing in tournament there yeah I
would like to visit India I've never
been there before and I have many
friends and fans there and I think in
the future whenever in there some
opportunities I would like to visit I'm
sure they would they would love it out
in India to see you there
all your fans meet you in person last
question here the segment from Christian
lakatos who was the strongest player
that you've ever played being the
strongest player that I've defeated I
defeated our 11 our own Ian last time we
played many years ago and he went out to
become an absolute superstar number two
player in the world for many many years
so that's the highest rated player I
defeated who went on to become a top
layer and also I drew against world
champion anatoly karpov and had several
wins against 2,700 there's a lot of our
viewers might know Aronian as the last
year's winner of the Sinquefield cup
right here at the singles chess club so
definitely a couple of strong players
there that's going to include our part
to segment with the version of Cobian
thanks for watching everybody please
tune in to our youtube channel often
keep checking for more videos including
more interviews with new grandmasters
thanks again everybody and Varzi so much
again getting here Hank